Trascrizione: Ilaria Feltrin
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Nei sentieri delle valli della vita
e indispensabile meditare sul senso
che intendiamo dare alla vita stessa.
Ma questo in relazione alla vita altrui,
però con la consapevolezza
che "Ogni parola è un percorso
quando rende gli uomini migliori
di quanto lo saranno domani.
Ognuno porta nel palmo delle sue mani
le chiavi di questo mondo,
che apre le porte a grandi destini".
E in questo cammino della vita,
sono persuaso che ogni essere umano
porta nel palmo della mano
le chiavi che aprono a grandi destini.
Ma queste porte si apriranno a condizione,
se sapremo immaginarci nell'altro,
immedesimarci nei sogni,
nei dolori, nei desideri
e nelle sofferenze dell'altra persona.
Ma per fare questo, abbiamo urgenza,
e abbiamo la necessità,
nonché la responsabilità,
di posare il peso dell'io
per abbracciare la stoica
leggerezza del noi:
ma che è un noi elegante,
un noi relazionale,
un noi capace di calarsi
nei bassifondi dell'umanità.
Un noi empatico, altruista,
generoso, solidale,
perché la trasformazione
della disperazione in speranza
passa attraverso la condivisione
delle nostre aspirazioni
in una prospettiva collettiva.
Ma per fare questo,
abbiamo bisogno dall'altra parte
di tornare a condividere
i nostri sentimenti
individuali d'infelicità
in un cammino di ricerca
di felicità collettiva.
Ma allo stesso tempo,
mi chiedo e vi chiedo:
possiamo davvero dirci felici,
se lo sfruttamento dell'uomo sull'uomo
continua a diventare la regola
della nostra società?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici
se il paradigma economico,
fondato sullo spirito dell'avidità
e alla base della nostra società,
continua a schiacciare
milioni di esseri umani
sotto il rullo compressore
dell'abbruttimento, dell'invisibilità,
dello sfruttamento, dell'indifferenza?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici
se una parte della nostra comunità,
della nostra popolazione,
della nostra società
continua a subire
forme articolate e disarticolate,
diverse, latenti e invisibili
di discriminazione, di sfruttamento
e di disuguaglianze
per motivi legati
all'orientamento sessuale,
al genere, al colore della pelle,
alla diversa provenienza geografica,
alla diversa fede religiosa manifestata,
o alla diversa estrazione sociale?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici,
se le nuove generazioni continuano
a vivere in solitudine,
nel travaglio dell'anima,
ma allo stesso tempo risucchiati
in quelle viscere
del silenzio asfissiante?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici,
se le lavoratrici e i lavoratori
non riescono a soddisfare
i loro bisogni vitali,
delle lore creature, dei loro cari,
delle loro famiglie,
a causa di una precarietà
esistenziale asfissiante,
di abbruttimento, di sfruttamento arcaico
nell'era dell'economia digitale,
però attraverso condizioni
che richiamano quell'era arcaica?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici,
se la dittatura della meritocrazia
omologatrice e alienante
ha finito per snaturare
le unicità creatrici,
generando infelicità?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici
se le persone che vivono
forme diverse di disabilità
continuano ad essere trasformate
in oggetti della nostra società?
Possiamo davvero dirci felici,
mentre i nostri giovani vengono costretti
a lasciare i propri cari,
i propri genitori
andando altrove alla ricerca
di una vita dignitosa
mentre altri si ritrovano
con muri di indifferenza alzati?
Soggetti, persone diverse
accomunati dagli stessi bisogni:
la ricerca della felicità.
Allora mi chiedo e vi chiedo:
le risposte a queste domande
ci dovrebbero far meditare?
Richiamando la nostra attenzione
sulle parole di Jean Marie Adiafi,
che era un poeta ivoriano,
e diceva queste parole:
"Un popolo che non sa più interpretare
i propri segni, i propri miti,
i propri simboli,
diventa estraneo a sé stesso.
Perde la fede nel proprio destino".
Noi ci dobbiamo interrogare chiedendoci,
resistendo alla bulimia del presentismo
e meditando sulle ragioni
che sono alla base dell'infelicità
generale e generalizzante,
quale senso vogliamo dare
alla nostra vita.
Per fare questo, ci dobbiamo
calare in modo radicale,
ma la radicalità sta nella postura
di tornare ad immedesimarsi
nelle condizioni di chi è asfissiato
dall'invisibilità,
di chi è asfissiato
dalle disuguaglianze sociali,
di chi è asfissiato da forme latenti,
visibili e invisibili di disuguaglianze.
Ma per far questo,
dobbiamo non solo meditare
ma dobbiamo tornare
a dare senso alla vita,
che per me risiede nell esaltare
la bellezza dell'Umano,
trasformando la disperazione in speranza,
trasformando la rassegnazione
in quel percorso
che ci permette di rimettere al centro
quell'entusiasmo generatore di creatività.
Ma allo stesso tempo,
questo ci porta a dire
che la nostra, di felicità,
non può non manifestarsi
se non attraverso la felicità altrui.
Questo non vuol dire tornare ad essere
quelli che eravamo prima.
Albert Camus lo dice
con parole molto semplici:
"Non abbiamo il tempo
di essere noi stessi.
Ma abbiamo il tempo di essere felici".
La mia di convinzione,
il cuore, e l'anima,
la fonte d'ispirazione del mio agire,
quando dico "il mio"
intendo "il mio" relazionale, generoso,
che si mette al servizio
di un'aspirazione collettiva.
E non è un Io che rinuncia,
ma è un Io che è capace di dire no
a quei processi, a quelle forme
che sono alla base
di tante disuguaglianze,
di tante invisibilità,
di tante infelicità;
è un no a quei modelli
che in realtà sono un sì,
un cammino verso la felicità,
alla ricerca della felicità.
Che non è il mio, di cammino;
è il nostro, di cammino,
che consiste nell'esaltare,
dal fango dell'immiserimento,
la bellezza estetica della vita,
dell'umano, della generosità.
E le chiavi di queste porte
le troviamo nelle nostre mani.
Parte dal liberarci dalla catene
che abbiamo nella nostra mente,
quelle catene dell'indifferenza,
dell'assuefazione,
del "ci siamo abituati".
Noi non ci dobbiamo mai abituare,
perché ciò porta alla banalizzazione;
e la banalità del male
è stata alla base di tanti processi
che la nostra umanità non deve
in nessun modo tornare a richiamare.
Le chiavi di questa felicità
risiedono nelle nostre mani
se sapremo interpretare questa felicità
in una prospettiva collettiva,
generatrice di un nuovo
umanesimo equo, solidale,
con alla base un modello economico
al servizio dell'umano, della persona.
Grazie.
(Applausi)